[Music]
part of the week it's almost over for me
i'm almost done it's wednesday
clap
stop clapping they'll do whatever i say
happy wednesday everyone well not if
you're whoopi goldberg aka karen johnson
yeah who knew whoopi was a karen
i thought that was only for white people
like toyota priuses and skiing
roll it francis
good morning and welcome to the view um
you all saw the news whoopi will be back
here in two weeks
okay
oh it's so cute when one of their side
gets punished they sulk like they ran
out of raw cookie dough in the green
room yeah abc suspended whoopi for two
weeks because she said the holocaust had
nothing to do with race
she said this on a show called the view
which makes everything about race
except now
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about race
because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
yeah that's heroically stupid
even for the view
what did she think hitler meant when he
said master race the 100 meter dash at
the berlin olympics
so for the first time in the views
history it's not about race just some
whites exterminating six million other
whites so what's the big deal her
reasoning reminds me of the guy who
looks at black on black crime and says
that's just them doing what they do
of course it's that if that callous
person were me or you we would be
canceled faster than a tinder date with
andrew cuomo
but thanks to liberal privilege whoopi
hangs on which is fine since she
apologized but not before digging an
even deeper hole than the one in her
head here she is on colbert which is
french for crushing boar
besides i feel
being black when we talk about race it's
a very different thing to me
so i said that i i felt that the
holocaust wasn't about race people were
very angry and they said no no we are a
race and i i understand i understand i i
felt differently this wasn't based on
the skin you couldn't tell who was
jewish they
they had issues
with ethnicity
not with race because most of the nazis
were white people and most of the people
they were attacking were white people so
to me i'm thinking how can you
how can you say it's about race if you
are fighting each other
well talk about putting ben gay on a
sunburn
and i guess colbert was too enthralled
by whippy's logic to push back he gave
about as much resistance as brian
stelter at the cheesecake factory
so what to do next well you go on the
view again and read the prepared
boilerplate apology straight off the
prompter and barely pretend you believe
it yourself
it is indeed about race because hitler
and the nazis consider jews to be an
inferior race now words matter and mine
are no exception
i
regret my comments as i said and i stand
corrected i also stand with the jewish
people
that's a flip
so even though whoopi wouldn't ever
defend me
i'm here to defend her
first anyone going for deep political or
her story is historical analysis from
the view
they deserve what they get that's like
watching the real housewives of atlanta
to learn more about the civil war
calling the view a lively show of
opinion is like saying jeffrey dahmer
was on the keto diet
but this is a country of free speech and
that includes the view remember free
speech is about the worst kind of speech
not the best and the view is without
fail the worst it's the show that makes
gloria steinem think maybe women should
have stayed in the kitchen
they make the jibbering homeless on your
street corner sound like the first
continental congress
of course the media is way more offended
by joe rogan's thoughts on kovid than
this rewriting of the holocaust and
hilariously it was the view
that wanted joe rogan censored
hasn't he been also chastised and
corrected and then he just goes back to
his craziness again i mean i don't know
that he can be
reformed and that's from a fright wigged
clown that's had more offensive crap fly
out of her pie hole than a busted sewer
pipe
but it's interesting how many allies
whoopi has to save her here's another
bozo
everyone knows whoopi goldberg she's
been on tv for decades if you don't know
her heart then you haven't been watching
this cancel culture
is getting so out of hand oh now it's
out of hand
you shut up you only care because you
know her for once try defending someone
you don't like or agree with which is
what we do and what i'm doing with
whoopi i don't know her i don't agree
with her but i'll defend her even if she
won't ever defend me
but whoopi actually did a great service
because what she said
is exactly what critical theory is
saying
remember that stuff that the left denied
was in classrooms but was in as many
schools as frozen pizza and tick tock
users and remember how few could
actually explain it well whoopi did a
bang-up job articulating their premise
and it's that whites are incapable of
being victims they live to oppress and
therefore they cannot be victims even of
each other when the nazis exterminated
jews it was just white on white crime
who cares especially if you're black as
researcher christopher ruffo says crt
points out that whiteness is already
racist by its very color which seems
pretty racist and it allows you to lump
jews in with the rest of the evil whites
like the nazis serial killers and the
cast of seinfeld
and when they're in when you become
inconvenient to their cause blacks
asians and hispanics become white too
just ask larry elder or any black person
who isn't to the left of karl marx
who if i remember correctly was white
but crt is designed to place people in
only two racial boxes white versus black
where jews asians latinos and other
lighter-skinned non-whites may find
themselves shoehorned into the
oppressors box if they don't act right
and especially if they reject crt
true if you don't fall in line then
you're as bad as a nazi or worse a white
guy race according to crt is only
important to the color line between
white and black and everything else is
irrelevant and that's how the holocaust
gets whitewashed
so goldberg a jewish name she
appropriated said on tv what crt experts
have been expounding for years that in
the hierarchy of oppression whiteness
sits alone at the top like the fats and
sugars at the top of the food chart and
you can never judge success struggle or
failure any other way and to maintain
that hierarchy you equate nazis with
jews under the umbrella of whiteness
now really i don't think whoopi meant
all of that
but given that she's a goldberg you know
she should have known better
[Applause]
hilarious welcome tonight's guest
she's killed more deer than interstate
80
townhall.com editor and fox news
contributor katie pavlich
it took him just over 10 years to
conquer the comedy scene in alaska now
he's set his sights on new york
actor writer comedian jamie lissau
geez burn more bridges than an arsonist
with an easy pass fox news contributor
co tube
and he once stubbed his toe on a pyramid
my massive sidekick in the nwa's world
television champion tyrus
so tyrus i go to you first for no gee i
wonder why
you and i shall never part no no okay uh
i love color purple yes you know greg i
i agree with you
about 85 right really in it as always
i'll take that um
two things that were on the view
one you cannot have conversations with
people you're not comfortable with right
and what we saw on that show was whoopi
was going down
her own personal beliefs were coming out
and
her peers said she's hanging herself
let's enjoy the fire really you think
that
bayer said
ask her a question again to get her
repeated then you saw when your friend
has been suspended she's gone okay
where whoopi was coming from i
understand whoopi is coming from
the older
the older african-american perspective
on racism which american has when
america has dumbed down race to one
thing either you're black or you're
white
which is
demeaning to black people because they
don't care if you're jamaican or you're
african or you're from australia you
don't get that right you don't get that
identity you're just black
so the way she was describing it was she
was trying to from the american
african-american perspective is that
you're
white so you get a pass
but where she's wrong is
the jews are the one group because of
their religious beliefs that they're
still separated and they get it from
both sides
and there's also this resentment
especially
in the 60s 70s and 80s so when she was
giving her perspective she was wrong
because she didn't think about and she
said it ethnicity yeah because
the the racism in the world
is far more direct it's about dna it's
bloodline that's way of scotland ireland
britain it's not whiteland yeah you know
they're all different and they have
horrible names for each other right and
they know the difference between this
and that and you know what i'm saying
and african americans would always
relate to that but
she's been around the world enough to
where she should have known better but
when you work for a show and this is a
reliable source remember bodyguard for
life yeah
that during the breaks they all go to
the green room they don't speak to each
other right they're not friends crabs in
a bucket and the one thing we know about
the other side
well crabs is a bucket one tries to
crawl out get your ass back in here
you've been with us and the other thing
crabs do is they eat each other
and that's yeah you should crabs got it
rough i don't know i don't know a lot
about
but that's what they do
they are didn't look upset yeah she
didn't say i've known her for this and
then she's a good person she said she's
gone for two weeks you know that okay
but that might have been a legal thing
though don't you think because like
whenever we've done that we all do the
thing like oh well
i'm sorry i missed her interview where
she came out and was talking about what
be the person and how good she was and
yeah you know and that and here's the
deal there was a moment
for redemption
she could have said whoopi you're
missing the point yeah it's about
ethnicity i understand your struggles
but here's this but they didn't do that
they were like ooh watch her burn they
did that's what you do on tv though
jamie you're white
and you're in the whitest state in the
world alaska um did this story reach
alaska
so i'm going to be honest with greg i
would like to never hear from whoopi
again and i think the view
should be canceled oh i just want to get
that off my chest
do you have a lot of what did you ask me
that was unrelated to what we're talking
about i want to hear any of your latest
view jokes so
i did look up i knew whoopi goldberg had
to be a fake name yes isn't it funny
when you hear like a serious story and
they're like then whoopi said you're
like they should use her real name this
sounds insane you know
you know how that's how you figure out
your view name you know that thing was
going around it was like to get your
porn star name yeah you take like the
name of your first pet and then like the
road the street you grew up on yes yes
mine doesn't even make sense i grew up
on tool avenue and i had a cat named
gigantic it doesn't even make any sense
um
but your view name is your favorite
childhood prank followed by your
favorite jewish name so i would be like
hand buzzer horowitz
um
to be serious this was crazy to me
because
the the colbert thing was where she
doubles down right and you get to see
the truth which is fine but then it was
almost like sad to see like the coerced
apology right like what what what is the
point why i haven't bothered it's not
cancelled culture it's take two weeks
off and come back culturally yes they
will see they get to take off two weeks
culture we get the cancer culture
because joy behar if any of us did
anything like that they they all of them
would come after us especially tyrus i
would assume but also you because you
know you like going well of course
obviously i'm surprised i'm even on the
show because you know be very careful if
you come on show greg your career could
be great jeopardy
no you're right i mean we can forgive
her right she did apologize the
suspension after the apology maybe was
too much but this forgiveness and move
on and learn and grow and this kind of
behavior doesn't work one way yeah so if
we're going to engage in that the left
has to do it too and the left has been
waging a war on anybody who strays from
any kind of line of what they believe in
and have destroyed people's careers
their lives they don't care if you're
homeless now on the street that's their
goal actually and it this incident i
think proves how shallow the
conversation on the view has become the
book they were talking about on the
holocaust if she would have read the
first page it's a quote by hitler that
says the jews are undoubtedly a race but
they are not human right page one so she
could have prevented all of this by just
doing a little bit of studying but it's
all about her world view and the
critical race theory thing yeah critical
race theory and this idea of seeing
everything through this new prism of
intersectionality on the left leads to a
gross distortion of history whether it's
the holocaust or the foundation of the
country it forces you to kind of push
your own ideology into history without
context or the facts and that's exactly
what she tried to do final point there
are black jews yes there are ethiopian
jews so not all jews are white uh so you
know we're talking a lot about white
jews think that we should acknowledge
the rest of the soul would probably have
something to say about that yeah yeah
cat is not a black jew really no but i
want to ask you i i'm sad because whoopi
is my favorite person on the view she's
the only one i could probably hang out
with he has to be right yeah
it's like being that it's like
being the tallest dwarf you have her on
here yeah it's two weeks off
oh that'd be great but she's she's uh
they say that she's claiming that she
might quit
yeah look there's a few things where you
know like if you're on tv and you have
to talk about it you're like well gotta
be really careful right and like the
holocaust is definitely one of those
things so it's wild to me that someone
would get out there and be like hitler
actually not a racist but that's
that's wild but again
everyone says dumb stuff in conversation
not everyone converses on television
about a bunch of random stuff every
single day so stuff like this is gonna
happen and i don't think she should have
even been suspended not because she
wasn't wrong because she was wrong but
if she wouldn't have said that she would
have never known she was wrong or why
she was wrong and she apologized so we
should forgive because it's impossible
to not say something we're doing it we
do a show every night and i've been
doing this since red eye days i mean
it's going to happen
that these things will happen it could
be a short circuit in the brain or a
casual throw-off line or an emotional
moment or an emotional moment and i mean
or you know and it's like and then all
yeah you wish you could do a better job
but the difference is we're being
audited as we're talking like
what amazes me is that people can't tell
the difference between like an expert
and
people having a conversation right it's
like going after rogan
yeah it's like it's like that literally
talks for 18 hours
so no one allows redemption yeah yeah
there's no redemption there's no
forgiveness but we're going to change
that right because
oh we've got a huge announcement jamie
is getting a hysterectomy no i'm kidding
we are taking the show on the road again
i'm so excited february 21st to the 25th
we are headed to texas yeah we're
leaving the country
we'll be at the iconic ghillies in
dallas all week long to get your free
free tickets you go to foxnews.com
gutfeld and look for the link on the
side of the page and i don't mean
sausage link
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else